THIS IS THE FIRST
MEETING OF THESE TWO AZ
HALL.
CRAZY BOUNCE, SPEZZA,
OFF THE CORNER GLASS,
AND SPEZZA CLOSET.
AND THE MATT GRZELCYK,
THEY GET A LITTLE
CROSSED UP ON A
POSSESSION PLAY.
PASTRNAK ! PASTRNAK
GETS  THE GOAL. UP
CURTIS LAZAR NIGHT,
SETTING UP
AND IT RIELLY POPS THE
REBOUND   SLIDE IT
BACK AGAINST THE
THE PUCK. SCORES !
BLOCKED BY KERFBACK TO
SCORES !  4-1, MAPLE
AREA, YOU ARE IN
MATTHEWS.
THE BACKEND, TO SIDE,
AND MATTHEWS CLOSES.
THE REBOUND FINDS
SCORES!
ALPHA 47 ON THE OD.
I AM GOING TO LOOK AT
THIS SIXTH GOAL BY THE
GOAL.
THAT IS NOT ENOUGH OF
BRINGS OUT GETS
KNOCKED OUT OF HAND,
AND CLIFTON OFF THE
END BOARDS, AND SMITH
SE
CLIFTON, HIS SHOT IS
RIGHT ON THE
ALL THE WAY IN, AND
SCORES
COULD HAVE BEEN.
THAT PUCK IS ALREADY Ja
>> Jack: HERE IS
KENDRICK NICHOLSON,
RENDERING